[Music]
[Music]
mmm
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to
find practical advice that you can use
in your everyday life
hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined together
today by my co-host dr greg sadler and
our special guest
michael devito and today we are talking
about
professional sports fandom and a
rational life so we're going to be
tackling the question about whether
being a fan
can or can't be part of a life oriented
by
rationality so we're going to go into a
lot more depth about this but first we
want to introduce our
special guest for this episode michael
devito
actually our first guest on the wisdom
for life
show so we're really honored to have you
here
mike played defensive end
first at the university of maine and
then for the new york jets
uh for a number of seasons then finished
out his
his career in the nfl with the kansas
city chiefs
while he was at the university of maine
mike majored in accounting and then
after he retired from football he went
on to earn
an m.a and msc and he's currently a phd
student
in philosophy of all fields at the
university of birmingham
working on among other things issues of
free will and determinism and how
epistemology
and paradox bear upon these so we've got
somebody who's really like a triple
threat when we want to discuss these
issues that we're going to be getting
into about fandom because mike
not only has been on both sides of the
fan player
fence we could call it but also is
somebody who is well versed in
philosophy so we really have you
happy to have you here on the the show
and we're looking forward to a
conversation
despite the fact that we you know are
rooting for
different teams right you mentioned that
you've played against our packers
a number of times yes well greg dan
thank you guys so much for having me on
the show it's
really uh an honor to be here and i'll
i'll start real quick with the story so
uh playing in the in the nfl you know
you don't normally feel like a fan right
you're around guys and you're around
these guys who are
you know big time almost celebrity
status figures
uh and you don't know you know you're
around them every day
uh but there are some guys who transcend
that and one of those guys was brett
favre
i remember in 2000 2008
brett favre uh signed with the jets when
i was with the jets and i remember the
first time he walked in the locker room
and all the guys were just like wow
everybody's jaw just dropped like wow
that's pretty far
you know normally with other players you
don't care that's how i felt the first
time i met greg sadler
because i i have been watching you on
youtube and any you know i've started my
my
master's degrees in philosophy in 2016
and any time i had an issue
or i needed an extra lecture or to get
caught up on kant or
augustine or whoever it was right to
greg sadler's podcast and so
uh it is it really is an honor to be
here and i remember the first time we
met on zoom i was like that same feeling
that
brett favre like oh my goodness i can't
believe greg sadler is on the other side
of the
the uh uh uh video right now so uh
seriously no i i really mean that and
it's it really is an honor to be here so
thank you guys well we're
we're really happy to have you here as
as well and we're hoping we can tap your
brain in a number of different ways
to get a lot of insights about you know
how players view fans too um because
well you and i were talking about this
at another time and this might be a good
good place to bring up some other
anecdotes i remember you mentioning that
as a jets player in certain places that
you would go
the fans not even in the stadium but in
the places that you were staying the
hotels and stuff
would make it hard for opposing teams
so and you said that the patriots were
particularly bad that way but i imagine
it's not just there right
well you'd be surprised greg because uh
it it really is notorious in new england
and especially when you're playing for
the jets right because you got the
patriots
jets this is like one of the biggest
rivalries in football um
and so yeah we would have to be
strategic whenever we were playing new
england
about where we were staying because if
you stayed especially if you stayed
in the boston new england area that
the fans or the patriots i don't put it
past the patriots to find us
but somebody would find us and like
clockwork
something would happen right it would be
uh you know the food
the food that was catered for the for
that week didn't show up or
um the this happened more than once the
fire alarm
would go off at two o'clock in the
morning and all the the night before the
game and all the guys would have to go
outside and wake us up and so uh yeah
new england was one of those places that
you just knew and so what we ended up
doing was staying
all the way out in rhode island about
45-50 minutes away
from the stadium yeah and so now you had
to get up early to travel out there but
uh
yeah the patriots are gonna find any way
to beat you and even on saturday when
you get to the hotel they're gonna try
to mess you up and so uh
so yeah it was it was notoriously bad in
new england so that's
it that's like a war of attrition yeah i
mean that's kind of interesting because
it goes beyond just the stadium and the
places just outside of the stadium
where you you expect a lot of back and
forth sort of sort of stuff between
fans of of rival teams and you know
giving giving the other team a hard time
and that covers like a whole
geographical area
you know where it's permeated by what
would you call it like
a certain sort of fandom that we we
might view as
definitely irrational and maybe bad for
for the game in some ways yeah i
oh i'm sorry dan go ahead it makes me
think of like okay so
fan is derived from the word fanatic and
so like
on on the worst case and maybe it will
take the the patriots fan here or like
maybe some of the
the really negative things that you see
from some of the uh uh philadelphia
eagles fan
put these at one end of the spectrum of
like okay
you're taking this too far i guess
you're taking this on outside of the
context that you really
need to for this particular thing and
we're talking about
how this uh modern usage of this
fandom needs to have is is this like
wide spectrum
and i guess right here in this the
central question is
where should we actually put ourselves
on this spectrum
for a something that you consider a
sports team and how much is that going
to subsume your life
right i i think it's a great question to
ask and uh
it's something that since i've retired
i've pondered more
because uh uh i imagine
the more i become a fan the more i get
addicted to the game and there
and when you're watching your former
team or your former buddies or or guys
that you really care about coaches who
care about it adds another element of
uh maybe addictiveness and i've had a
really tough time since i've retired
watching football but going back to when
i was playing and maybe something that
will add more make this
point more salient there were a few
places
oakland you said philly new england
where if my family was going to the game
i would tell them listen you
don't wear our jerseys don't let them
know
because you knew that they could you
know get thro they could
have the threat of physical violence
heckling but like physical
violence um and that always would make
me so
nervous and it just i but i never took
the step back to think wow that really
is a silly
that's a silly thing that this is this
is such
like you said greg permeated the culture
permeated that area that
it becomes like a gang right being a fan
of a team is like being
in in the in that gang yeah i think uh
and if you're with the
oh i'm sorry go go ahead i was just
saying if you're from the rival
you know you're from the rival area you
know that's that's war it's what you're
you're entering
uh into a war zone almost and so not to
over dramatize it but i mean it is
something as a player you have to worry
about that's that's something that
i mean we've been noting this sort of
thing in western culture for
over 2 000 years marcus aurelius
in the meditations he he begins with
this this whole chapter about thanks
about this and thanks about this
and one is that from his i think it's
from his teacher fronto dan you can
correct me if i'm wrong
he learned not to be a supporter of the
blues or the greens these these are the
chariot racing
teams and people would go nuts like they
would you know
not only would did you have the thing of
like if your team wins you go crazy if
your team loses you go crazy
even when the chariots were like just
running down the track fans would be
punching each other
and and going after each other and so
when we think about is is
it okay to be a fan you know these these
really negative things
come up and they have throughout the
centuries i mean it's and it's not
necessarily
just about sports you can think about
medieval villages where
every once in a while people would just
get a whole bunch of clubs and go over
to the the next village over and start
racing trouble with yeah
those guys come out there's something
there's something endemic and irrational
to group activity especially when it
involves you know
let's call it muscular uh activity right
we and young men too um although there's
plenty of women that that can certainly
give them a run for their money
and so i think one of the issues that we
we have to grapple with and we're going
to do that here
is how do we how do we avoid that stuff
or deal with that stuff when it happens
and
and be rational but also
you know enjoy ourselves as sports fans
and maybe some people would say well you
can't do that you got to give up
sports all together because it's always
going to be fundamentally irrational all
three of us clearly are people who have
not made that choice
well it's interesting greg because since
i retired i actually
this is the first year that i've been
able to return to the game
and watch it but i actually did have to
say
okay unless i'm gonna cut let's say i
have something i have to commentate on
like
you have a number of interviews that
people would ask me to do or talk about
the game or something like that i would
i would watch a game for those reasons
if i had a
interview commitment but outside of that
i had to step away from it uh
the first my my first year out of the
nfl so just a little back story 2015 was
my last season
and during that year i had sustained two
concussions during the season
uh and they were back to back and it was
right at the time where the movie
concussion had come out
and all of this new data had come out
about uh
brain trauma in the nfl and uh cte and
all of that and so
um i got done with that season
and i'm contemplating retirement with my
wife and she had been
pretty quiet about it and um
about march when free agency is about to
start the chiefs call and say hey we
want you to come back we're going to put
a contract on the table we want you to
come back
and you know this is two months inside
plates i'd forgotten about all the
concussions and injuries and how tough
the season was before
and i said oh yeah well okay fine you
know that this is what i do i play
football
and i brought it to my wife and she
basically said you know if you go you're
going by yourself because i'm not i'm
not going i can't watch you
you know knocked out on the field
anymore i'm done we have another kid on
the way our
my youngest son was done was born in uh
november of that year and so we knew he
was coming
and so now i'm watching the chiefs that
season and i know i could be out there
with them
and i'm watching them play and it just
was a hell like i i was just such an
awful person to be around
while you were watching while i was
watching it
and like when the chiefs did did good i
would
i would be crazy because i wish i was
there with them yeah and when they did
bad it was like i need to be
experiencing that suffering with them
and it just made me an awful husband an
awful father he just didn't want to be
anywhere near me and then to make
matters worse
a bunch of the guys on the defensive
line the position i played got hurt
and so in november the chiefs called my
agent and said is he ready because we
need we need somebody like his hey has
he been training as mike been training
because we want him
to come back for the rest of the season
and so i was like
seven games i miss training camp i miss
all tas i miss all the crap that is a
veteran you don't want to do
and my wife is still like you know again
if you go you're going
uh on your own and so obviously i'm not
gonna leave her
my newborn uh and so now i'm watching
them struggle the chiefs struggle
with a defensive line that's all beat up
and i'm the guy they need me there
and it just my entire life was consumed
with this hell
uh and i there was nothing i can do to
kick it so after the 2016 season i said
i'm done
i can't i can't do this anymore it's
it's totally
just it's totally all-consuming i mean i
had no i
i had no idea until recently i had to
actually be a fan and watch the game
uh like you said in a rational sort of
no
way what's the difference then
between being a fan
in a rational way and being one of these
crazy fans because
i mean what you're describing is
something different right it's it's
a i'm i'm belong to this organization
but some of the crazy fans
almost seem to think that they are parts
of the organization
as well so dan i had a thought about
this because
it seems like we have two organizations
that are kind of symbiotic here
we have the the actual football team the
business the organization that there is
and and maybe you want to even like make
this into a tri
try symbiotic thing okay um in that we
have
uh maybe three three organizations you
have the core team
you have the organization that is the
um the money making the like the
ownership
and then you have this uh third group
this is the fans that are
like they feed off of they feed
off of all of the uh pageantry and all
of the storylines that are going on with
this
um but and they feel like they are part
of it but they are actually not it's
kind of like
um people who uh
create these relationships with people
that are like youtube celebrities
even though they have no or just any
celebrity whatsoever
and they feel like this deep connection
to them even though it's really kind of
like this one
way uh this you know vicarious living
this life
that that i think is characteristic of
fandom
in in general you know i mean you look
at all the different cons that exist
precisely so that people can go and
think about star trek for example right
so some of those those uh original
cast members are still out there going
to
cons and like meeting people how many
people have they met like it's got to be
some of them hundreds of thousands at
this point
there's no way you can be have a
personal connection with all of these
and then you know we've got all the all
the newer ones and and people really do
get
kind of obsessive with it you know and
and well go ahead
oh i'm sorry greg i was just going to
say on the flip side it's funny how fast
things change so i remember in the
article you wrote greg you talked about
how
you took us through the history of the
packers right and how
growing up they stung which has not
always been illustrious yeah
yeah right but then you get to the aaron
rodgers era and now they're you know
getting the super bowl the brett favre
of aaron rodgers
error and they're doing well but then in
2017
you talk about how rogers gets hurt and
now
all of a sudden every the the
expectation of it set so high
that everybody's turning on the team and
hey we this can't happen like we
deserved
everybody forgot about yeah and so it's
interesting because i was thinking about
that and
the chiefs just just experienced that so
right so when i went to kansas city in
2013 the year before
they had finished the season 2 and 14.
so andy reed comes in in 2013
and we win the first we win nine games
in a row right we finished the season
11-5
get back to the playoffs and it's
basically been like that every year for
kansas city
since andy reid got out there now they
lose they
take it all last year they win the super
bowl right take it all the way now to
week five
this year and they they just lost last
week to the raiders
and you can go on twitter and on social
media
and see chiefs fans calling for
defensive players and guys who messed up
the game to
to get fired be gone yeah there's a kid
there's a
there's a player on the chiefs who who
basically
single-handedly got them to the playoffs
and not patrick's mom's on on defense he
was able to
make a couple key stops that turned the
momentum in these games
and he's really one of the primary
reasons outside of mahomes that they
got to the super bowl and won the super
bowl and he didn't have a good game
against the raiders
in week five last week and they're
calling for him to get released
so it's just it's even fast how crazy it
is that
they love you and then they they'll turn
on you in a second you know
it's like it's almost like an idol a
failed idol you know where
your god doesn't show up you know and i
think that what's what's going on there
is so everybody's driven by by
motives right and you can when you think
about
what motives go into being a good fan
it's like caring about the organization
wanting nobody to get hurt you know
everybody to play at their best
these sorts of things that we can we can
put into
let's call it an ethos of of you know
good sportsmanship and play
but i think there's a lot of people out
there that really value
success not just for themselves because
very often they're not experiencing
success but success of whatever it is
that they're
involved with and it could be a sports
team i think for a lot of people it is a
sports team
it could also be like um the success of
you know their their local rotary you
know organization it could be
um their corporation or something like
that and
they're so invested in success
as the really good thing that anybody
who can't
for even just temporarily as you're
pointing out measure up to that
get rid of them you know and and that's
sort of a recipe for making yourself
unhappy and also not having a good
relationship with
whatever object it is that you're
supposed to be you know showing
affection or loyalty to you know and
so going back to the packers thing and
actually i mean
we should talk about some some really
really diehard fans
i mean it's one thing to be a packers
fan and grow up in the 70s and 80s when
the team just had losing season after
losing season
and everybody was you know saying oh
this is the year they're going to come
back
we'd get all excited and then we'd see
these these terrible games
and even in the brett favre era there
were a lot of games where it was almost
like the packers mo
three really good quarters and then blow
it in the fourth you know
and you feel like ah attackers you know
um
but but think about browns fans you know
i mean the browns are hot right now
fortunately for like the first time in
what four decades
uh i think yeah um and i know people who
are the lions
well yeah the lions too yeah it's
well greg i just talked to my friend joe
thomas today who was there it was their
hall of fame
left tackle that was there for for so
long and he
and i we asked him one of my buddies
asked him uh
you know do you ever wish the team was
winning like this when you were there
and he said you know
i was like i think he said i was one and
31
his last two or three years yeah one in
31 his last two years
um that's a man i could not imagine
that you guys you that is absolute
hell going into an organization that's
lost that much i mean it's just the
black cloud that must have been over
that play uh so yeah
yeah and the fans that are that are
showing up they must
really be committed you know um
because because they they can't get
bragging rights or anything like that
that's right so they must get something
else out of that and we see
communities uh do a lot of things and as
we as like
social creatures on this this embrace of
a community allows us to
kind of get away from our individuality
and and let us
uh subsume ourselves within this
community and
doing this allows us to have some sort
of common purpose
and it allows us to kind of transcend
self-interest in exchange for group
interest
and like you were talking about mike
about like you know oh
you know you forget about all the pain
and how hard it is
you know you're two months out of it all
you are thinking about is that like that
feeling of community and working
together with your brothers down in the
trenches
and just being part of that group and
and we derive so much
like i guess pleasure and and for a lot
of people like a source of meaning
yeah that you you you can't and if you
want to extend it to
the browns like even though that they
they were losing
they're still you if you're in the
locker room and you're working with
these guys every day
you have a commitment to these people
and you you
you as long as the the locker room is
not toxic then you're gonna like you
know do everything you can to help out
your
your
brothers there and i think that also
extends a little bit to
these fandoms that are around these
people
because they they create a community and
it does it's not that they have to win
or lose it's the community that they're
actually valuing
yeah that's a great point and i think
that was the biggest difference
between my time with the jets and my
time in kansas city
with the jets you're in new york you're
in the city
you're still you're still a small fish
right there's there's a million other
things for people to do
out there there's you know you've got
brad pitt walking down the street you
know so
people don't care too much you know they
care about their team
but it's not kansas city it was a
community it felt
like college again where it was like the
whole
the whole community was was was really
that 12th man
right so you would i would go out to the
to the plaza or go out to the mall or it
was like
hey there's devito like man like it but
it wasn't it wasn't like a fan it was
like a brother thing you know brother
sister it was like this is
this is our family and uh yeah they they
really
embodied that more what you're saying
dan than than new york did so yeah but
no that's right it's exactly right it's
true
that's interesting you know green bay
because they're based up in
in green bay sometimes there's a feeling
like that they do a lot of community
things but i remember my my sister was
up in the fox cities and she was working
as a bartender in this pool hall and a
lot of the packers players used to come
in there
but this is this is much earlier this is
um
you know in in the the 90s and this is
you know the team now is pretty squeaky
clean um
back then wasn't quite the case you know
and the packers would come in
and like some of the other people like
leave by by the other door because
they're like these guys are going to be
trouble you know
sort of like the raiders have been at
other other times you know
and and i so i think that like that
ethos
uh component is is really important too
you know people value their team
for different reasons i mean like the
eagles you know clearly
winning an aggression is all they i i
i'm going to generalize here i'm going
to say that's all they really care about
right
i would say something kind of similar
holds for for the the pats fans
um but i think with other organizations
there are
there's values that come to permeate the
organization and they can be there or
not be there you know i i would also i'm
also going to go out on sort of a
controversial limb here
although i don't think it's that
controversial in milwaukee and say that
you know getting rid of mccarthy was was
really instrumental in making the
packers a
functioning organization again because
he'd been kind of like a lead weight
just sitting
on on the team for for quite a while um
he was quite good at the start you know
but somehow something didn't didn't work
and that the team got up more and more
out of sync now watching them when
they're playing they're actually really
enjoying themselves and that that
i mean we use the word camaraderie and
family and ethos i think that when
when you have an organization that that
has those sorts of characteristics even
if they're not necessarily winning games
the fans can sense something and i don't
know how to express this that that well
you know what is this something that
they're
maybe maybe you have a better way of of
expressing it you know dan
maybe it's it's hard to put your finger
on right but it
so maybe this this will help flesh it
out a little bit but
um so i i've i've lived in new england
basically my whole life right so i
played new york played in
uh played against city but grew up in in
new england and
live in maine my wife's from maine and
so uh
i come back here every off season and
obviously last year kansas city wins the
super bowl
and now now new england's used to win
the super bowl every other year so
everybody up here is
you know they're so spoiled up here
but it was so funny the reaction i got
from
patriots fans up here it was almost like
they were like mike you won
you did it you did it you i was like
i've been retired i retired four years
ago i've been here with you the whole
time
what do you mean they're like no you did
it man can't say did it you won like you
got
like i did more interviews last year
during the playoffs
interesting in kansas city they were in
my house
i'm signing autographs i'm doing local
media thing
like guys but i can't remind them like
you guys know like i didn't this isn't
i've been here with you yeah
i don't not on the team but it just you
could just see
with them like you're saying that ethos
that family like even when it came to
you know me being a chiefs player not
even they just
assume that no no yeah you're you're
them that's that's you
like you're an extension of them uh and
so i don't know if that helped push it
out but just such a you it just kind of
speaks to what you're saying like oh
yeah
i couldn't wrap my head around it you
know yeah you're
part of the team even though it's it's
endearing
it's uh you spend enough time that you
just you're you're a chiefs
player for life you're just part of the
family that's right that's right and now
the flip the flip side of that
now you know playing six years for the
jets and coming home to new england
yeah i remember people like didn't want
anything to do with me wow they were so
happy that i went to kansas city
when i was playing for the jets forget i
remember my dad
went to a game in new england i would
play in new england
my dad went to one of the games and he
was with a bunch of his friends
and they had a house that they owned
near the stadium so he's over there
and he said oh i got to use the bathroom
can i use the bathroom and they said no
oh and then and he's like wait what he
said no your son plays for the jets like
you can't come in my house
i was like this is his friends and they
wouldn't even let him in the house and
they really wouldn't it wasn't like a
joke like they wouldn't let him in the
house to use the bathroom
i wonder what that's like what they were
accomplishing by
taking that you know is it not that or
maybe it's just like an idea of disgust
that
they they have such negative feelings
towards the jets
that anything that is associated with
the jets is seen as
disgusting contaminated by
it did feel that way yeah that's it
didn't feel like that dan
which is totally crazy to think yeah
it's highly irrational
you know and this is this is again that
that side of fandom that we're
we don't want to slip into those sorts
of things right right
so maybe we should talk about some of
the uh the bad things that fans have
done and see like
where they're failing here okay so uh
we've got um
i guess terms of like motivations and
values and how can we have like
good or bad motivations in this case
talking about uh
mike's dad here and their their
motivations like
are they actually trying to hurt you or
are they are they valuing something
um so highly like the the pats
that anything that would be even the the
i guess the pats are so
sacred in the sense that anything that
would
potentially harm that sacredness needs
to be kept out at all costs
yeah jeez yeah it's it's um i mean
it demands the sacrifice of other values
like for example i mean later on
we're gonna hopefully talk about virtues
associated with good fandom and i think
one of those
is hospitality you know yeah
something that was fine you know it was
recognized as a value in ancient greece
it also played a role in monastic
culture and down through the
the ages but that's almost like the
opposite of hospitality it sees the the
other person as
not guest but enemy you know yeah
yeah and you know what's funny if you
want to throw off
an opposing team when you show
hospitality it's like we don't know
how to react i remember really i was
playing at maine
and we went to play nebraska and
so nebraska is not afraid of maine
coming you know one double a maine
coming to play nebraska at their house
to open up the season you know we're the
team they're going to beat up on and get
going
and so that the fans it wasn't i don't
know how they are their regular games
but like
we're walking out they're like hey guys
good to see you like i'm glad you guys
you guys made it out this way you know
they're like
and we were like wait what like why why
are you being nice
to us you know they're totally nice and
we were totally we were shook you know
we had no idea
how to react it's like it's almost you
could play reverse psychology on them
you know it's only
in their mind more because guys are so
used to getting cussed out
and although this is kind of like the
one of the basis
of um like a lot of uh christian thought
of like turning the other cheek
that uh and it's also like found in uh
game theory talking about how
um how can you get the best out of
people and if you're constantly like
someone
um uh makes a move against you then
you you want to move against them in
response and this just
goes tit for tat but tit for tat um once
one person makes a bad
move then everyone's stuck in this bad
moves back and forth
and so what actually works best in these
cases
is a tit-for-tat but every once in a
while you
are benevolent and you say even though
that you did something negative towards
me i'm going to do something positive
and that's the one thing that gets you
out of these
uh negative tit for tat like just back
and forth
such an interesting i never thought of
it like that but you're right
the sd just keeps escalating when it's
the tit-for-tat
but you take you know i i laugh about
this because
i've i've used this piece of advice my
my wife likes to watch like the bravo
housewife shows where it's just drama
from beginning to end
and i'm always saying you know if one
person just said oh you know what i'm
sorry i did that like
i shouldn't have done that you know they
wouldn't have a show because they would
just
all the everything would just dissolve
right but you just got this tit for tat
for tip for that
so i never thought of it in the context
of fans and sports but it's a really
it's an it is it's an interesting point
i think it i think it would
it would be it could be a good strategic
move for an opposing
uh fan base to use i think it would
totally throw me off
yeah that's interesting because it it
implies that so like
the packers i'm i'm going to use them as
an example
again because i i got to go to lambeau
for the very first time
last november for for a division
rival game against the bears and
the the packers
you know packers and bears are
traditional long-standing rivalry i'm
actually a fan of both and i get a lot
of grief from from people
uh on both sides of the you know the
fence about that
but when you actually are at lambeau
even when it's the bears who are playing
and they also will
you know like play the bears still suck
there's a good heartedness about things
um you know you have packers and bears
fans
in regalia sitting next to each other
talking to each other
you know finding out where you go for a
hot dog or things like
people pass the hot dog they don't throw
your hot dog away because you're a bears
fan or something like that
i don't know what it's like for the
teams exactly you know
but it's you know the fan experience of
is is one of hospitality so i think that
could become to be expected then right
we'll go to lambeau and everyone will
treat us nice then there wouldn't be any
strategic advantage to it then
yeah yeah that's right it it's
interesting to see
like certain cultures that have grown up
in really harsh conditions
tend to uh create a culture of really
openness
and on a hospitality you look in
um the places in the middle east
um have a long tradition of being very
open and saying like okay someone comes
you open the door and you you
allow them in and this also happens in
like i grew up in montana and so there's
this certain amount of a tradition of
this because
it's a harsh environment um and i wonder
if just because
uh lambo's way up north and it's cold
and they
you need to work together a little bit
there's you know if you live in
it too nice of a environment then it's
easier for you to be more independent
whereas if you live in a harsh
environment
you you have to depend on other people
in order to
you have survived maybe not nowadays but
at least those are
cultures that uh spring up in there yeah
you know what though some of the best
fans are
chargers fans so they were out in san
diego they were like the nicest
people in the world so i don't know if
that would be a counter example
but it was like san diego was one of the
one places where i was like oh you guys
can wear your jerseys and do whatever
you know san diego people like just hug
hug you know that's actually a good
segue into something i was wanting to
ask you about um which is
from a player's perspective you you
encounter a lot of fans
what makes a fan a good fan like the
kind of person who's not
a pain in the the rear who you've got to
deal with somebody who you actually look
forward to to engaging with what makes
i i i'm willing to bet it's not like
they they you know bow down and they're
like oh i'm not worthy you know
that sort of stuff that must get very
old very quickly what makes
what makes for good fans
yeah no it's a good question i i agree
with you i
you don't want at least at least i
didn't want
the fan that was just going to uh
you know yeah prop you up and as some as
some idol
um but you're i really like i said going
back to kansas city i really enjoyed
the fans out there because it really
it really was a family atmosphere
everywhere we went was a family
atmosphere
and uh the fans would embrace you
as part of the part of the family i mean
i remember some of my first weeks over
there uh just how excited the fans were
to see me and it was like wow how did
the
how did the fans even know me i'm so i'm
this kind of obscure player who's only
been out here for a couple weeks
and uh and they already know who i am
but it it is it is just a sort of
respect like hey
and we're in this together and uh
they'll still hold you accountable right
so like i always appreciated fans who
would say the truth they'd be like hey
you know david's got to do better he's
got to step it up uh but not
over the top you know you know you have
one bad game and they're they're calling
for your head
um yeah and so yeah so that's it's in
the it's a
in the in the uh in the middle of the
the bow down to you or worship you uh
versus the
oh you you had one slip up so you pack
your bags and go home
um so yeah no no i mean kansas city has
has fantastic fans i think they do a
great job i would imagine it'd be
similar to the fans in green bay yeah
very similar uh
uh climates yeah i mean you do you do
get some
people who are uh like on the boards or
things like that or they can they can
check in they're like this person needs
to go that person needs to go so i think
you're always going to have some of
those
those fans but but in general it seems
to be more like
even if they're losing it's like well
you got to back the pack and
you know go do a good job guys sort of
sort of yeah and and it's really
great go ahead oh i'm sorry
i was just gonna say um
the pack your bags thing drives me nuts
because
from fans because we don't do this
like you don't go to the guy from state
farm and say you know oh you you know
you had a bad day today they need to
fire you and send you home so you can't
provide
for your family you know what i mean
like i just i wish if there was one
thing i would say
i wish fans would would recognize this
like when you're calling for somebody to
get fired you're calling
for them for their job to be in jeopard
for them to lose their job and might not
get i mean the nfl
is is not a forgiving place i mean you
lose your job
more than one or two times and you're
not you're not back in and so
i just and i would have uh
you know i would have even friends up
here in new england who say hey
we we hope you don't play well this year
because we don't want you guys to beat
new england so like they would say we
hope you do
poorly at your job so you know what i
mean so yeah it's like
you guys wouldn't you don't do that to
the guy uh
working at shaw's at those at the
supermarket or at dunkin donuts like
i understand it's it's different it's it
is a game so it's not
totally comparable but like i wish
fans would have more sympathy for the
fact that when you're calling for
somebody's head you you want them to
literally
lose their ability to provide for
themselves and their family
uh and and it's just it's stressful it's
it's incredibly stressful when you're
playing for a losing team
as a player if you're not having a good
season and you know wow my salary could
be on the line do i have enough to make
it if i'm if i
you know get cut i can't get back into
the nfl uh will i get another chance i
mean the stress that players and coaches
go through
uh when they're you know when guys
aren't playing well or things aren't
going well is incredible so
if there was one thing that going back
to the questions before what makes a
good fan
yeah that would be one important point
like just recognize when you're calling
for someone to get fired it's
it's a real job that you're calling for
somebody to get fired to
yeah you get fired from you know there's
too much uh
separation from the fact that you're
actually talking about human beings
and they they have you know uh emotions
and they can be hurt by people
just because you don't get to know them
on a personal level doesn't mean that
they're
not actually humans that's that's a
really interesting point
you know um it's sort of like
treating them as if they're like
characters npcs essentially in a video
game
or like you're you're watching some
drama on tv like i mean
i i used when i was younger i used to
actually talk to the to the tv every
once in a while
uh you know and say that's a stupid i
didn't say obviously this this sort of
thing i said in other words but that's a
stupid decision that person
want to you know be be cut from whatever
is going on in some adventure thing
right
um how happy to be so dumb uh no that's
totally irrational
because obviously those people aren't
hearing you you're talking to yourself
to a screen right yeah and and and
people are
forgetting that when they're dealing
with actual teams because those are
actual people
yeah and then you it's much worse for
football like it is a general thing to
see people
yell at the players on the screen it was
like
they can't hear you well like you are
just yelling into the ether here
it is producing nothing and it's just
getting you riled up players
coaches and raps right
yeah yeah and and
it's funny greg until i read it this is
the truth until i read your article a
couple weeks ago
because i was just as guilty of of that
and i've never
even reflected on it i've reflected on
fandom
from an aspect of time or like
like is it a time well spent to really
sit at my sit on my couch and watch tv
yeah for four hours like is that
is that really being productive uh is
that really making the best use of my
time but i never
thought of the irrationality of like i
totally
with the chiefs two years ago um
were in the afc championship game one
game away from going to the to the super
bowl and they lost the patriots
and i was i'm sweating this whole game
and i'm yelling at the tv
and i'm yelling at the guys and i'm
yelling at brady and i'm doing
you brought this up in your article
about how people will do these weird
superstitious things where they'll sit
down and
like i'll i'm doing that like i'm like i
was on the i was sitting on the table
before
and we scored like i'm going right back
over there just and
like i don't it's so it's so funny
because
very rarely does anybody step out and
say what a si
this is nuts like if you came from from
an alien race and came down and look
at humanity you would say intelligent
life hasn't made it
this you know hasn't evolved yet on this
planet because look at these people
at least during games yeah yeah it's
certain games yeah that's right so uh i
wanted to bring up like
this is kind of very similar how
uh emil durkheim kind of describes
religions
as you know groups that are a unified
system of beliefs and
practices that unite members into a
single moral community
and so you can see there's a parallel
between
a lot of these practices these
superstitions
and what is really powerful about these
particular types of organization
is it has three things that interact
with each other believing
doing and belonging and by doing you are
uh perpetuating your own belief in the
thing
and doing these things then produces
other people to say
oh this person is part of the group and
that makes you be
more um welcome to be part of the group
unless you belong
and it binds people together but it also
blinds us and we then we turn things
into sacred objects
and so for football we can say you know
tom brady is the goat
if you're a pats fan tom brady's a goat
you can't say anything
nothing will ever say is like you know
six rings that's all you have to say
six rings and you can just plug your
ears and go la la la to anything else
um uh but like there are they're really
beneficial things to these types of
groups it reduces free riders
it increases trustworthiness within that
group
and it increases commitment to that
group by re
repeatingly doing these things um but it
also
it's it's very much uh benefits for the
in-group
and that does not mean that these things
at all benefit anyone in the out group
yeah yeah that's really that's really
interesting that's really
there's a book to be written about this
i'm sure that i'm sure there has but
um not not to go off on too far of a
tangent but i
i think about the political climate that
we're in right now
and i think about you know my time in
kansas city
and how i could sit down in a room
with an atheist and two muslims
and two liberals and a conservative
and we can have this fantastic
respectful disagreement conversation
which we did in kansas city we had some
really good thinkers
uh out there on the team and yet because
we were all working for that goal and we
were part of that community and it was
like
that never because we would go on that
field and go to battle together
you never got into it was never anything
that you hated the other guy because of
their different views
yeah um because you knew there was
something bigger and it's like
man i wish we could get to the that
place
in politics where we recognized the fact
that we're
in america that we're all on this i mean
everybody's on the same team but as an
american society we're all the same like
we all want to work
for the same thing we're all like we're
all trying to reach the same goals it's
like
having this greater community and as a
as a in a political sense
uh i think would uh i just know from my
time in kansas city
uh we were able to have the
disagreements that people are having now
but
it was so much less volatile and heated
up and so
i have a so i look at my fandom
of the packers in in at least partially
a distance way but i also use it
specifically
because i want to scratch that community
edge
and i don't want to do that with
politics because politics is going to
divide us
and if i if i like the packers and i
root for the packers and i might root
against the bears or something
there's nothing that's materially being
hurt by those
the fans or the bears you know i don't
want them to get hurt on the field as
well
um but but me rooting against
the half of the country or you know the
other political party
just means that i want them to have a
worse life and i
can't uh wrap my head around why i
should
have that be the basis of a fandom that
will blind me to
the benefits that we can use together
yeah so you're saying you you don't want
to take that sports analogy and apply it
to politics because now you're going to
see
the other side as sort of the other team
where they're the enemy
where is that i'm not i'm saying that
people do absolutely turn fandom the
political party into the fandom
i'm saying that i try to stymie that
by uh using that itch to have a fandom
to be part
of a group that you know because we are
social creatures and i use
football as that thing that scratches
that itch
and like okay and then i can just
divorce myself from the
the fandoms that kind of arise from
politics it's you know it's interesting
so
two things one with the politics thing
you know
if we are if we were all one big team
wouldn't we need to be like one big team
by opposition to somebody else like you
know china or russia or something yeah
which we did have like during the cold
war you know uh
but the other thing is so i i you know i
love talking football
and i enjoy it and i i like you know i
watch to see what other teams are doing
and stuff like that so i can actually
like talk with
people from from other areas about that
but i know that especially among
academics there's a lot of people that
are not into sports at all
and as soon as you start bringing that
up they're like i don't do sports ball
because that's their code for it
and and i think that the reason why they
say that is they feel excluded you know
they feel like they're not
they're not part of the conversation and
and i can understand that because
there's plenty of fandoms that i just
you know don't fit into
when it comes to music i know metal and
i know a few other things here and there
but if people are talking about all
sorts of other genres
i'm i'm at sea and now i don't usually
let it bother me because they're not
i don't feel like they're they're
deliberately excluding me but i think a
lot of people
do feel like if we're focusing heavily
on sports
fandom um we're leaving them out in a
way
you know yeah i see and you're talking
specifically about
the academic that's that's big in the
academic world
i would say that there's a higher
concentration of them in in
academia but you can find people that
just aren't into
that you know that that sort of fandom
all over the place
and they may be into some sort of other
fandom of their own you know
yeah the tech scene was like that a lot
especially in
in the northwest until seattle started
being good
and then people started wearing jerseys
and things yeah
well that's interesting yeah
it's interesting because i get to see
both worlds and
i as a you know looking at my football
career
i i know firsthand how much work it took
to got to get to the top
right to be one of the best yeah in the
world and so now
making the transition to the academic
world has been incredibly
humbling and like i said at the start of
the show greg i have been a fan of yours
because i see the level that you're at
right the level
of the philosopher that you have become
and it's just like
you know it's like being the high school
kid again and watching
you know the tom brady and those guys
and then seriously and so
i i wonder if people need to recognize
especially professional academics and
professional tech people it's like
you guys you guys have made it to the
top too like
like to be a professional philosopher i
when i first started studying philosophy
one of my first ethics class we read the
kant's groundwork that's a small
book great i had it memorized and i
didn't know what he was talking about i
could i
i watched your stuff on con probably i
probably spent hundreds of hours
and i just for that that's a little bit
it's partly a function of kant though
kant is
is he's writing in his own code right
he's sort of like doing if you're
thinking about like exercises right
he's sort of like um an obstacle course
packed into one little block
you know right maybe in 3d too but now
but now greg but now you've done
i mean i can find any philosopher
a history of philosophy i can go to your
channel and find
you giving a detailed well not yet
sure not yet because there's still a lot
of gaps but there there are
there at least some that i can do that
with but you know
i was going to joke and say the good
thing about academia and philosophy
is i don't have guys trying to tackle me
you know yes
i don't have to run down the field you
know worrying about whether
whether i'm going to damage a tendon or
something like that
yeah i did but see but sometimes i'd be
like man i i would take that over trying
to i look at the critique of pure reason
after i got done with the groundwork and
i'm like well that's going to sit on the
bookshelf because that would take me
my whole life to get through that you
know so i think i say all this to say
uh you know i wonder if people
recognize that especially in
professional areas like what you're
doing greg
you've made it to the top like you're a
pro you're a pro you know and i wonder
if that would help
sort of bridge the gap where you're not
feeling excluded because because i
i have a ton of respect and i want to be
a part of the academic community because
i see the pros and cons damn i want to
be like one of the pro you know
there's a really funny story and i think
dan is the one who reminded me of it
most recently
about aj air this british philosopher
meeting mike tyson
and mike tyson was giving giving some
girl a hard time
uh trying to hit on her or something
like that and and
aj air was like in his 80s and he
intervened at a party
and mike tyson was like i'm the
heavyweight champion of the world i'll
knock you out you know
and aj air said listen we're both you
know highly respected professionals in
our respective
fields you know i i don't know that i'm
the champion but i'm pretty close why
don't why don't we go have a drink
together
yeah tyson was like yeah okay this this
guy is uh
that's fantastic and it's so true it's
so true that's
it's been incredibly humbling since i
retired right because
what i didn't originally recognize when
i got done with football
well when you make it to the top and i
was like oh i'll be good at anything i
do right i'm interested
yeah and and so i've been you know i
started martial arts
into us jiu jitsu and stuff like that
that's been five years
i i haven't beaten anybody i get the
crap just
crappy that yeah you know what i mean
philosophy it's taken it took
two master's degrees to get into a phd
program and i have all the assets in the
world all the time in the world
a love for it i can just study it
constantly and it took two masters
it took five years to finally get good
enough to
get into a phd program and so it's been
incredibly humbling to see
that's a segue into something i wanted
to ask you to talk about
just a little bit and we and we're
getting close to the end so
don't go into like super detail but why
philosophy of all fields
i mean i'm happy that you're studying it
but it's it's kind of a surprise
so what was what was the motivation
it's interesting greg i don't know if i
just got hit the right way
it started i became a christian in 2007
and one of the first things that really
changed when i became a christian was
wanting to study and read i don't i
don't know if i had read a
book front to back prior to 2007.
i mean seriously and so i mean that's
talk about the college system like i
made it through college without reading
a book front to back so uh
maybe maybe something needs to happen
there but um
yeah no i i started with theology
and then i i one thing i couldn't stand
about theology this is kind of i saw the
philosopher early was
everybody was so held onto their views
right so like when i when i started i i
didn't believe in the trinity i held to
a
like a oneness model of god and i talked
to my tritany friends and they'd be like
nope
you're going to hell like it's over you
know like you can't
and then i talk to my oneness buddies
i'm like hey that trinity people had
some good stuff like nope going to hell
i can't believe the truth
so i was like i'm out look i'm out i
can't do this i want to have a
discussion
you know so then it morphed into
apologetics
uh but then studying more apologetics i
was like oh no no it's not it's not
really apologetics like
i like apologetics because politics and
philosophy are very similar
but like i don't really feel like
sitting around and debating
the fine-tuning argument for hours you
know let me i was like
i want to study you know i want to study
abstract objects and i want to study the
fore-knowledge and freedom problem and
so i i just and then i found my home
uh in 2016 after i took my first
philosophy religion course
i found my home in philosophy i was like
i just
started reading intro you know or
graduate level textbooks and
uh cont and i was like oh i'm i'm hooked
i'm a di
it was like i'm really addicted like i
know it's bad when i don't want to go
lift weights
because i want to read wow you know like
that's bad
well thank you very much for that we got
to get to our practice here
yeah so if we want to be rational fans
maybe a stoic practice could be helpful
for us we call it the reserve clause
and i think this could be helpful when
you're watching a game or
you know doing anything else do you want
to say a little bit more about it dan
um so yeah like the idea of uh
in christianity the reserve clause is
god willing and so in
in stoic uh philosophy it's it's fate
willing and so like
i'm going to try to do this thing you
know god willing or faint willing it's
like i
mean the whole idea is to remove your
desire for the thing
to i have an aim for a thing and i'm
going to desire what actually happens
and hooray if the thing the thing that
i'm aiming for
actually happens that's great if it
doesn't happen that's also great i now
have a new position of new reality and i
can work towards that goal or you can
find a new goal
but you don't desire the things that you
don't have control over
that's right so
go ahead uh and so i guess today we're
going to leave you with the words
of vince lombardi the price of success
is hard work dedication to the job at
hand and determination
that whenever we win or lose we have
applied the best of ourselves
to the task at hand
[Music]
[Music]
you